but I'm in a new phase of my life in
which what I want to do is get the best
principles from everyone I've been
passing along my principles and so on
and it's been people find it helpful
what a joy it is as you must experience
when people say oh my God you've changed
my life but other people can do it
you're doing it and I say to so many
people who are really very very
successful people who have never written
down their principles that they're going
to die with them and if they instead
write them down and make them clear then
they're teaching other people because
there's a life Arc right we have
experiences that things of decisions we
make that make us successful okay
including how to deal with pain and so
if we write those things down we can
help other people and I think like I
probably won't be around
um to speak to my grandchildren in the
way that I would like to then but they
will have those principles